mais 8000 idoles dans la poutre les
doigts dans la poulie une horreur
[Musique]
que je vous raconte ce qui m'est arrivé
hier soir
parce que hier soir il y a eu une
tempête avec tellement de vent ça a fait
tomber toutes les tuiles du toit
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été chercher une caisse une corde
une poulie et une goutte il y a accroché
la poutre sur le toit bien
la poulie et c'est un crochet la corde à
la caisse oui c'est monter la tête tout
en haut et pour claquer cette tienne la
hausse accroché la corde à un arbre j'ai
monté ma gueule sur le toit par les
scènes j'ai mis toutes les tuiles
coincées dans la tête quand la quête a
été pleine j'ai redescendu Michael par
les selles et c'est décroché la corde de
l'arbre
mais la caisse
qui était beaucoup plus lourde que moi
à commencer à décembre
et moi à monter
mais j'ai pas perdu mon sang-froid je me
suis bien accroché à la corde
laquelle c'est le descendait moi je
montais à mi-chemin la caisse c'est moi
ton chez Mike croisé
jusqu'au moment où j'ai été arrêté net
[Rires]
dans la poutre les doigts dans la poulie
une horreur quand je suis arrivé en haut
la caisse elle est arrivée en bas aussi
fort que moi je suis arrivé en haut sous
l'effet du centre la caisse elle a
explosion
toutes les filles qui étaient dans la
caisse elles se sont répandues partout
par terre la tête vide
c'est retrouver plus légère comme moi
et un commentaire
et moi descendre
amis
quand la caisse elle est arrivée en bas
j'aurais pu tomber sur du gazon ou sur
la table
puis tombez le cul sur les tuiles quand
les filles de la douleur j'ai perdu mon
sang-froid c'est la croix
qui s'est retrouvé plus lourd que ce que
il y avait plus rien au bout de la corde
affirmière décembre
amis chemin la caisse elle a rencontré
personne
et infini là alors l'hôpital ils m'ont
mis des plats partout sur la gueule de
haut en bas et quand j'ai vu qu'il
voulait m'accrocher la jambe à une
poulie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]